[Musique]
il ya quelques jours de cela vous vous
souvenez donc patrick esther vous avez
fait assister au début de l'expérience
de survie menée par quatre hommes dans
un abri antiatomique les quatre
aventuriers modernes ont tenu leur pari
ils sont restés huit jours dans l'abri
et ils sont ressortis ce matin
bien sûr patrick esther était encore là
ici à cinq mètres sous terre ils auront
passé huit jours dont la plus grande
partie dans le noir en attendant
l'instant où lussier briserait les
scellés et ouvrir la porte
un technicien un étudiant en psychologie
d'auteurs de bande dessinée est un
cuisinier au chômage
quatre hommes qui ne se connaissaient
pas auparavant une expérience de
cohabitation intéressante qui devrait
aussi permettre d'améliorer la technique
des abris anti atomiques
on a compté les heures de la dernière
journée a été la plus longue des
problèmes
déjà on ressent énormément de choses au
bout d'une semaine et un mois soit et et
non un champ mais envie de sentir un
dehors de descente à la rade d'entendre
des bruits - puis de manger aussi un
quelque chose une bonne viande et les
frites quelque chose de bien consistant
parce que bon ça n'a pas été toujours
très rose donc vous avez conçu en partie
cet abri aujourd'hui vous avez passé
huit jours dedans vous allez modifier
beaucoup de choses dans cet abri
pas grand chose peut-être au niveau des
ventilations oui c'est certain
ne serait-ce que
de nationaliser une un système de fer au
lieu de la faire manuellement monde à
faire avec un système de vélos sont
venus ce qui serait certainement moins
fatigante à ça c'est sûr au niveau des
waters revoir un petit peu
quantifier parce qu'on était quand même
juste fallu faire très très attention et
les odeurs vous ont pas gênée elle
d'autres vous gênez à vous en ce moment
parce que au niveau propreté je suis
voilà c'est mon rêve demain aussi
cependant pense souvent à l'euro
aujourd'hui vous pensez réellement qu'en
cas de guerre nucléaire
on pourrait vivre ici à moi reste que
ces quatre cobayes humains savait dès le
début il ressortirait de toute manière
de cet abri de 10 mètres carrés en cas
de guerre nucléaire tout serait bien sûr
très différent
[Musique]